Five additional
pages of classified
documents were found at President
Biden's
residence in that Wilmington
suburb in a room adjacent to the garage.
What's your reaction
to this latest development
Well, my concern
is that the
special counsel was called for,
but yet hours after that,
we still had the president's
personal attorneys
who have no security clearance,
still rummaging
around the president's residence
looking for things.
I mean,
that would essentially be a crime scene,
so to speak,
after the appointment
of a special counsel.
So, you know,
we have a lot of questions
for the National Archives.
We have a lot of questions
for the Department of Justice.
And hopefully
we'll be getting some answers very soon.
So you just just this morning,
you have a new letter to the White House
chief of staff, Ron
Clain, demanding more information
about these classified documents.
What more do you want to know
We want
to know
the visitor logs to the residence.
We want to know who had access
to the Biden Center for Diplomacy,
because this is the same
type of investigation that the Democrats
were so outraged
and launched and demanded happened
to President Trump.
What we see with President Biden
is there are multiple locations
we would never have known
about the possession
of the classified documents
were it
not for investigative reporting by CBS
that somehow
got a leak
to determine that this had happened
prior to the election.
So the administration
hasn't been transparent
about what's going on
with President Biden's
possession of classified documents.
And we just want equal treatment here.
With respect to how both
former President Trump and current
President Biden are being treated.
Former President Trump
is under an investigation
for his own classified documents.
There are about 20 in the case of Biden
for Trump, there are about
there are more than 300
classified documents at Mar a Lago.
A big difference here.
Just on the facts,
Trump did not fully comply
with the subpoena.
His lawyers
falsely told investigators
that they turned everything in.
Take a listen to what
you told CNN about the situation
last November.
I don't know much about that.
That's not something that
we've requested information
just to see what was going on
because I don't
know what documents were at Mar-A-Lago.
So, you know,
that's something
we're just waiting to see
what comes out in that.
But is it fair to say that investigation
won't be a priority?
That will not be a priority.
So what do you say to viewers
who don't understand
why President
Biden's documents
seem like a big priority for you?
But President Trump,
who took hundreds
more documents,
did not comply with the subpoena,
did not reach out
to the National Archives
or the Justice Department to say, hey,
we found these documents.
It's not a priority.
Do you only care
about classified documents
being mishandled
when Democrats do the mishandling
Absolutely not.
Look, we still don't know
what type of documents
President Trump had.
That's one of the questions we've asked
National Archives.
Just because Joe Biden's
lawyers said they turned over
five documents doesn't mean
they just turned over five documents.
They could have turned over
500 documents.
I'm sorry,
but I don't have a lot of confidence
in President Biden's personal lawyers.
At the end of the day,
the National Archives implied to us
at former Chairman Maloney's request
and told us that the National Archives
was working with the Trump administration
during the transition.
That's the last communication we had
with whether or not
the Archives
had worked with Trump on removal of
of all the documents
from the White House.
So we don't know exactly what
Trump has versus what Biden has.
At the end of the day,
my biggest concern
is that the classified documents,
to be honest with you.
My concern is how
there's such a discrepancy
in how former
President Trump
was treated by raiding Mar
a Lago, by getting the security cameras,
by taking pictures of documents
on the
on the floor, by going through
Melania's closet
versus Joe Biden was like,
okay, you're personal lawyers.
You don't have security clearance.
They can go through.
They can just look in and keep looking
and, you know, determine
whatever's there.
That's not equal treatment.
And we're very concerned.
And there's a lack of trust here
at Department of Justice
by House Republicans. That's the outrage.
So I get that
but there's a big difference
in how President Biden
and his team reacted
and how President Trump
and his team reacted.
The FBI searched Mar a Lago
because Trump for more than a year
refused to turn over documents
to the National Archives
and the Justice Department,
which was trying to get them back
into secure hands.
Trump and his lawyers lied about it.
Trump lied about not having classified
documents, did not keep them in a secure
location, did not comply with a subpoena,
but said he had
and that that search warrant,
which Trump
forced out into the open
through his legal master imaginations
that cited laws
that Trump might have violated,
including the Espionage Act
It's my understanding
that President Trump
did let the National Archives
go through on numerous occasions
Mar a Lago.
Looking at the documents,
what my understanding
is, and again,
we don't know
because we haven't been briefed,
was that President Trump was arguing
with National Archives
over what is classified and what is not.
As we've heard the president
say before,
the president
has the authority to declassify document.
Now, the question is whether or not
the president
actually declassified the documents.
The vice president
does not have the authority
to declassify.
Actually, the vice
the vice president does have
to be different. The vice president does.
And I think the vice president does
have that authority
that we disagree
that the vice president does.
But just just to put.
First of all,
you're asking for the visitor's logs
at President Biden's Greeneville
outside Wilmington.
Delaware home.
Are you also asking
for the visitor logs at Mar a Lago?
Because the issue
of whether or not sources
and methods are compromised,
whether or not
any of these documents
got into the wrong hands,
whether or not Biden or Trump
allowed documents
to be kept in a haphazard way
that exists, period.
And I'm wondering
why the request
for visitor logs in Greenville,
but not in Mar a Lago
Well,
we're doing the Biden
family influence peddling investigation.
And I can tell you what we've learned
just in the last few days from Biden's
mishandling of classified documents
is that
the Biden Center was funded primarily
through anonymous donations from China.
Was it a Biden center
or university transactions?
I know the University of Pennsylvania
was the University of Pennsylvania
that funneled it
through the Biden Center.
And then you have the Biden Center says
they didn't get any money
from from
Chinese anonymous donations
I mean, I get that
schools get money from Chinese donations,
but there is a pattern here.
Well, where is the
what the American people
are going to say from
our investigation
is a pattern of anonymous donations
going to hunter business deals,
to the Biden Center,
to the artwork that Hunter sold
at that art gallery in New York.
There's a pattern here
of anonymous
sources of money
flowing into Biden's
pockets and Biden interest.
And it's very concerning.
This is a national security risk.
That's my biggest concern.
And that's why we're pressing forward
with this investigation.
So I guess
the average American
who doesn't really care
whether the person you're investigating
has a D
or an R next to their name
might listen to this interview and think,
I don't have any problem
with anything he's investigating
when it comes to Biden.
But how come he's not investigating
all the same stuff
when it comes to Trump?
I mean,
there are questions
about influence peddling
when it comes to the Trump family.
There's questions about visitor logs
when it comes to Mar a Lago.
I mean,
if you are going to be doing
the Oversight
and Accountability Committee,
which you've renamed
for the American people,
not just for Republicans,
it would seem to me
that all of it should be investigated
and I
think the influence
peddling with respect to the Trump
administration will be a part
of our overall investigation
because both
Democrats and Republicans
have complained about this
with the previous two administrations.
So something needs to be done.
Also, something needs to be done
with respect
to have classified documents,
leave the White House
and go to the post-presidency
or post vice president.
That's another issue we try to
we will try to fix
from a legislative point of view.
But with respect
to investigating President Trump,
there have been so many investigations
of President Trump.
I don't feel like we need to spend
a whole lot of time
investigating President Trump
because the Democrats have done that
for the past six years.
So no one's been investigated
more than Donald Trump
who hasn't been investigated, Joe Biden.
And that's
why we're finally launching
an investigation of Joe Biden,
the House Oversight Committee.
One investigation
and I hope to have it wrapped up
as soon as possible.